parce qu'il y a quand même une question
lourde qui est posée avec la situation
de Monsieur Dupont-Moretti
en effet
il y avait une jurisprudence
auquel à laquelle le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron avait dit dès
le début de son premier quinquennat il
tenait
quand un ministre est mis en examen il
doit suspendre
sa fonction il doit démissionner il ne
doit plus être ministre souvenez-vous
que par exemple Monsieur Bayrou qui
était garde des sceaux adultes des
missionné et il l'a fait
et voilà qu'aujourd'hui on a un garde
des sceaux qui non seulement est mis en
examen mais renvoyé devant la Cour de
Justice de la République
et qui reste garde des sceaux donc
quelle est la cohérence
pourquoi certains ont dû démissionner et
d'autres ne le doivent pas deuxièmement
je constate que les avocats de Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti profère de très lourdes
accusations
contre des très hauts magistrats
pensaient qu'il traite de déloyauté
le
procureur général de la Cour de
cassation
la tête de toute la hiérarchie du
parquet
comment est-il possible
que les avocats du garde des sceaux
s'expriment ainsi et que lui soit garant
de l'impartialité de la justice
troisièmement
quand monsieur Mollens quittera ses
fonctions c'est-à-dire dans quelques
mois
c'est le garde des sceaux qui jouera un
rôle essentiel dans la nomination de son
successeur est-ce qu'on peut penser que
quelqu'un qui est devant la justice
devant la Cour de Justice de la
République
choisissent son accusateur est-ce qu'on
forme à l'indépendance
de la justice donc il y a là de graves
questions et je pense qu'il serait sage
que le président ou la première ministre
clarifie les choses
parce que ce qui se passe et vraiment
préoccupant par rapport à ce qui est
notre bien commun à savoir
l'indépendance de la justice
[Musique]